alors vous vous yassine belattar jeu ce
soir les petites annonces à faire je
crois
avant non mais non mais c'est vrai que
vous êtes candidat à la présidence mais
il sait ce que j'ai entendu mais c'est
vrai bah après surtout c'est un
électorat fort chez les coiffeurs mois
plus sérieusement j'ai décidé parce que
j'en ai je suis fatigué de la rentrée ce
que dit karim ce que dit yann aussi je
pense qu'on se trompe de campagne j'ai
honte franchement objectivement parce
que toute cette campagne se fait sur le
dos des musulmans se fait sur le dos des
gens des quartiers est objectivement il
ya des gens ici qui ont vécu des choses
et on les a vécus ensemble depuis bien
longtemps et je le dis à jordan bardella
je n'ai pas envie de décevoir moi je
m'appelle yassine belattar je suis sur
l'immigration marocaine et je vous dire
quelque chose et je vais rester je sais
pas pour qui ou vous roulez mais vous
êtes quand même teinté d'un discours qui
voudrait que la plupart des gens qui ont
une autre origine vont un jour rentrer
dans un pays qui n'ont jamais connu si
ce n'est la france j'aime victor hugo
j'aime tout en france j'aime tout ce que
la france m'a apporté d'être que pas
avec des gens de différents horizons et
j'ai décidé oui en effet parce que
zemmour j'en ai clairement marrer les
gens qui justement lui ont permis
d'arriver là où il en est céron un jour
mais juge j'aimerais vous dire quelque
chose de cérons kouassi faut vraiment à
la raison un héros sans nom mais je vais
traverser le plateau chargé au nom avait
deux fois je te le nom alors j'aime
jeudi à tremblay naulleau n'a pas
fini juste avec les menaces mais on juge
musulman face les mac mini jupe qui
regarde le reste pour vous qui nous
arrive je vous dis pour tous les gens
que vous menacez construire et vous
l'avez battu manchester vraiment lassant
des gens par jordi noir ivoire air dame
je vais au bout de mon respect géo dire
ça n'aurait pas si ça a commencé comme
ça non vous êtes ans avec l'avancé avec
des histoires ses très grands a commencé
avec gris mat
on alors pour aller hop la question
allait s'inverser eric naulleau
aujourd'hui la 15% et je vois le tout
avec zemmour essaie de faire la
différence je sais que c'est difficile
mais c'est pas eric naulleau qui à 15%
non mais moi je me présenterais mes la
semaine prochaine une émission c'est la
preuve que j'arrive pas à vous
différencie mais que tu es con en plus
d'être menaçante et beaucoup
n'ont m'écoute je veux laisser traiter
j'ai demandé la dissolution de
génération il
ne dit pas des conduits à râler au bout
d'un fil osséja si la condescendance du
petit facho juste pour un alias il a été
décidé frédéric leur a laissé bon eric
les ballons je commence à la voir leurs
arguments mais qu'est-ce qu'il va pas me
traiter de cinq ans traité de facho tout
laisse
aller au bout pour prouver à quel point
peut-être j'avais touché quelque chose
même chose et simplement tous les droits
ici tu n'as pas le droit de me traiter
de facho je peux aller où il est venu
non mais je pas le des prévenus mais je
tiens beaucoup de quoi de ta connerie et
jamais on en verra le bout de gras mais
on avait rallumé à ces enjeux sérieux la
région et les fachos à côté de vous
traiter les arrête toi alessio
secco vous allez si tu veux on part
derrière y'a pas de soucis du butin
aujourd'hui le taux d'abstention est
colossale dans les quartiers il ya des
91 % dans certaines villes où les gens
n'ont pas été votées le deal est simple
c'est eric zemmour prend conscience de
jour en jour dans la télé et nous on
subit et on en pièces tous les jours des
propos qui sont inadmissibles donc la
question est simple s'il y va j'y vais
je me présente à l'élection
présidentielle pour tenir tête à cette
française ce qu'on a vu ce soir pas de
condescendance cadence -une ça veut dire
quoi les insultes ça veut dire que si
eric zemmour se présente vous présenter
le lendemain d'accord je sois je peux
dire
[Applaudissements]